oh yeah
astronauts on board my tongue won't tow
which means having a palace as we all
can see
let us continue this discussion and the
the generator of the boys world
capitalist equation so that delightful
tidings of our socialist triumph may
pause for their cult imperialist hearts
as a bamboo spear so a ball of dim sum
tell us of the vast improvements to our
space explorers or we a very pleasant
living conditions that living room looks
very comfortable secretary far more
comfortable and spacious Zen mo home on
earth and I miss my wife at all thanks
to the company of my very experienced
comrade but the core here in Chinese
launch style is both romantic and
timelessly elegant
unfortunately the outhouse isn't heated
yes but the warm memories of the
emotional climax of the six plenary
session of the eighteen central
committee keep our hearts and digestive
tract at operating temperature my poopoo
is now floating in space
I personally thought that the recession
want the best of the whole season and I
count the days till the next season
premiere I have the cliffhanger at the
end of the episode and I'm anxious to
see if you ain't up together with tang
to me Oh
chato nearly as exciting as twice we are
also huge fans of People's Republic
excellent state propaganda news car team
when you're humble it is a constant
companion and works better than sleep
people's my personal faith is your
campaign against Korra
chan in the party we'd like to offer
food support in exchange for a small
cash injection also we rich to over
gratitude to party headquarters for the
test for the collective flag and the new
approach standing so far it is both
exceedingly comfortable and promotes
healthy blood flow in the head and
rectum thank you part too much
information
Oliver where Captain Kirk and mr. Spock
let me say it again
and I also speak for many taxidermic
members of the CPC Central Committee and
the entire Chinese modelling from
Tibbett to the South China Sea
when I say is it we are of and
civilization we shall probably return to
the Land of the Rising Sun and the
setting press freedom I'm looking
forward to season 200 I've met you I am
fully convinced that we will never see
you alive again but we will do our best
to preserve your memories as socialist
heroes for as long as we deem necessary
oh right time now for lunch have your
quick executions down to the respected
massage parlor happy ending it's a
freakin wicked baby and I'm about to
have some me some fun
[Music]